ein imam möchte einer frau nicht die
hand geben muslimische deutsche leisten
große hilfe bei den flüchtlingen
salafisten werben für den heiligen krieg
muslime sind abgeordnete des deutschen
bundestages der islam in deutschland hat
viele gesichter wird weltweit aber durch
morde und terror missbraucht und ist
vielen mitbürgern einfach fremd die
frage ob der islam zu deutschland gehört
die stellt sich angesichts der vielen
menschen die gerade aus syrien zu uns
kommen aber nicht mehr
aber welcher islam ich begrüße sie ganz
herzlich zu phoenix runde an unseren
themenabend im namen des islam und das
sind heute abend unsere gäste ich
begrüße sabatina james aus pakistan
stammen in österreich lebende ehemaligen
muslimen inzwischen konvertiert zum
christentum und islam kritikerin dies
botschafterin der
frauenrechtsorganisation terre de femmes
und hat den verein sabatina für die
gleichberechtigung muslimische frauen
gegründet
bei uns ist cola maryam hübsch
publizistin deutsch indischer herkunft
engagiert sich als muslimin für den
interreligiösen dialog und herzlich
willkommen dr guido steinberg
nahost-experte und islamwissenschaftler
der stiftung wissenschaft und politik
und jochen bittner redakteur der
wochenzeitung die zeit der viel zu dem
thema schreibt platz bekommen ihn james
sabatina james ist nicht ihr richtiger
name und sie konnten zu uns kommen nur
mit personenschutz
warum ist das so zunächst einmal ich
wurde
nachdem ich vom islam zum christentum
konvertiert bin von meiner familie mit
dem tod bedroht danach hat die polizei
maßnahmen für mich getroffen und ich
habe in der letzten zeit und bei
islamkritische videos gemacht und mein
team origin von islamisten bedroht und
so die drohung war dann achte auf deinen
kopf und schaut dass ein haus unter
polizeischutz gestellt wird und deswegen
habe ich personenschutz die drohung ging
es waren die mitarbeiter aber wissen wir
alle ihn noch gemeint sind sie damit ein
einzelfall im beim islam oder als muslim
nein es gibt ich glaube es gibt tausende
opfer des islamismus in deutschland und
was ich schlimm finde ist dass diese
opfer des islamismus keine stimme haben
und dass die täter hier bleiben dürfen
selbst wenn sie gewalt ausüben dass
ihnen keine konsequenzen weder vom staat
noch in einer anderen seite drohen und
dass die opfer keinen schutz haben nicht
einmal von der polizei
sie sagen aber sind opfer des islamismus
und sie auch opfer des islam
also ich glaube der islam ist ja ein
bestimmter begriff innerhalb des islam
gibt es verschiedene strömungen
wenn ich von dem islamismus spreche dann
meine ich den ursprünglichen islam nach
den lehrern mohammeds wissen der ersten
generation gelebt wurde und nicht im
modernisierten formen frau hübsch wenn
sie dann solche geschichte hören dass
frau james nicht frei ist sich zu
bewegen
für sie als muslimin was bedeutet das
wenn sie das hören sie sei traurig zu
hören dass ist auch erschrecken wir
wissen alle dass es dieser fromme dieser
pervertierten auswüchse gibt aber ich
glaube wir können auch acht muslime bin
ich ja gar nicht so weit dass ich sagen
würde ich leugne die krise des landes
macht glaube ich niemand also wir sind
uns ja alle einig dass die sogenannte
islamische welt sich in einer krise
befindet nicht in bezug auf ihre lehren
sondern bezug auf die praxis der muslime
in bezug auf das was in dieser region
stattfindet es ist eine politische krise
über die wir sprechen müssen alles ist
eben eine theologische krise nur das
interessante ist ja dass der prophet des
islam sales diese krise prophezeit hat
und diese prophezeien sind in der
islamischen welt sehr weit verbreitet
als in technologische prophezeiung die
darauf hindeuten dass es zu einer
solchen krise des islams kommen wird und
dass heute jemand wie frauen james muss
diese krise außer eben nicht sondern das
dann eben auch an der zeitpunkt kommen
wird wo eine reform nötig sein wird aber
nicht eine reform wie vielleicht haut
james gefordert oder andere sogenannte
islamkritiker die nämlich oft fordern
die glauben so der mittel müssten in
frage gestellt werden der koranische
verändert werden das ist nicht was ich
unter bevor meine sondern reform in dem
sinne dass muslime reformiert werden
müssen und dass über die auslegung
nachgedacht werden muss und der prophet
hat prophezeit ist das eben auch eine
zeit kommen wird wo dann eine reform
auch nötig sein wird also jetzt gedanken
jetzt natürlich die zeit ist körper
trotzdem darf ich feststellen dass sie
das was frau james passiert dass sie das
verurteilen definitiv also jeder
rationalen normale vernünftige mensch
hörte ein bisschen mitleid mit anderer
menschen hat muss das verurteilen und
das tun die allermeisten muslime
weltweit und wenn sie das annehmen
nein weil ich erst mal glaube dass frau
hübsch als vertreterin der ahmadiyya gar
nicht den islam sprechen kann also eine
gruppe die weniger als ein prozent des
islam bildet kann einfach nicht für den
islam sprechen
wir erklären es gleich nochmal und
zweitens auch weltweit werden die auch
mal dies ja gar nicht als muslime
betrachtet und sowie die buddhisten an
bruder die christen an christus zu
glauben die ahmadis und die lehre von
ahmad damit sind sie nicht repräsentativ
für den islam von der anzahl her nicht
und vom inhalt vernichten
da haben wir ja jemand der uns nachhilfe
geben kann der sich besonders gut
ausgeht beim islam herr steinberg was
wir jetzt hören die zwei verschiedenen
ansichten des islam dann noch die gruppe
der amadea erklären sie uns was ist der
islam und wie müssen wir ihn verstehen
der islam ist zunächst mal eine religion
und religionen werden immer von menschen
mit inhalt gefüllt deswegen es ist
tatsächlich probleme problematisch über
den islam zu sprechen
ganz einfach deshalb weil eben menschen
menschen ihn ausmachen und deswegen
haben wir es ja auch mit so vielen
unterschiedlichen schattierungen zu tun
ich glaube die erste frage die wir
erklären müssen für uns ist was wir denn
eigentlich meinen wenn wir über islam
sprechen und die meisten
islamwissenschaftler gehen eben davon
aus dass so ein bin ein bestimmtes
minimum an referenzpunkten gegeben
werden gegeben sein muss bei mir ist das
eine referenz auf den propheten mohammed
eine referenz zum koran und die
selbstbezeichnung natürlich als muslim
und das sind dann eben die muslime die
sind das gegen der gegenstand der
islamwissenschaft und das reicht für
mich zunächst einmal das heißt dann das
selbstverständlich auch die ahmadis zum
islam gehören wenn sie das wollen
die aleviten wenn sie denn sagen dass
sie muslime sind sind das auch und die
sunniten und die schiiten inhalieren
ganz verschiedenen ausprägungen die
frage was denn jetzt guter und was
richtiger was red
präsentator islam ist das sollen die
muslime unter sich besprechen da werde
ich mich auf gar keinen fall einmischen
das wäre vielleicht auch wichtig jetzt
für unsere diskussion dass wir einfach
dass sie sind muslime sie waren muslimen
und dass wir die einzelnen untergruppen
macht es einfach etwas zu kompliziert
ist ich würde gerne mein twitter in die
diskussion ein
neben warum ist es denn so schwer den
islam zu verstehen ich glaube es ist so
schwer ist den islam zu verstehen weil
er in seiner geschichte und bis heute
also vieles gedient hat als religion für
die einen aber auch als als rechts
quelle für viele muslime bis heute gilt
also es gibt nicht die klassische
trennung wie im christentum zwischen
göttlichen reich und weltlichen bereich
er wurde auch schon benutzt als
ideologisch politische kampf kultur im
schiitischen islam die iranische
revolution hat ihn so benutzt er wurde
auch schon benutzt von seit coop als
anti westliches programm kodex einer
kultur
das heißt es genauso schwierig den islam
zu trennen von einer politischen
dimension wie es leicht ist ihn zu
verbinden mit einer politischen
dimension sehen wir heute wieder beim
bso lange islam lässt sich einfach
leicht ja gebrauchen missbrauchen die
nächste frage als als politische
programmatik und es fehlt einfach
deswegen diese unbestimmtheit zwischen
gebrauchen missbrauchen das fehlt
sozusagen der archimedische punkt was
ist der eigentliche islam leben von der
perversion des islam gesprochen der frau
james passiert ist ich würde ihnen gerne
zustimmen aber um zu sagen was eine
perversion es muss man zunächst mal
bestimmen was normalität ist und das ist
das problem
was ist denn der islam für sie also
zunächst einmal es heißt ja immer wieder
so das was mir passiert ist hat nichts
mit dem islam zu tun wenn die gewalt
gegenüber frauen und nichtmuslimen
nichts mit dem islam zu tun hätte dann
ist es als würde man sagen prophet
mohammed damals und die islamischen
staaten heute haben nichts mit dem islam
zu tun denn dort gibt es diese diese
gewalt und mohammed hat die gewalt
gelehrt und praktiziert und die
islamischen staaten tun dass heute noch
in form der scharia und gerade in meiner
heimat pakistan werden wegen sony zu
tode verurteilt asia bibi
eine mutter von fünf kindern sitzt seit
jahren wasser nie im gefängnis wird
betreuen gerade eine iranische familie
wo die familie zum christentum
konvertiert ist der vater wurde
hingerichtet
das iranische strafrecht also die
islamischen staaten selbst haben eine
eigene menschenrechtserklärung
herausgegeben eine islamische
menschenrechtserklärung und diese
menschenrechtserklärung sagt ganz klar
dass frauen und nichtmuslime keine
richtigen menschen im rechtlich
vollwertigem sinne sind wenn dann
natürlich deutsche islamwissenschaftler
ihre interpretation ergeben sagen hier
sehen muslime so das ist die eine sache
aber ich wünschte mir herr steinberg
hätte recht aber seine meinung wieder
nicht gehört die meinung von al gaddafi
ist für viele muslime entscheiden denn
40 millionen menschen auf al jazira
anschauen und der betrachtet die ahmadis
als nicht muslime sowie auch pakistan
und andere staaten sie dürfen die nicht
mal nach mekka hat machen gehen also ich
finde das muss man schon mit sehen dass
die meinung von von deutschen islam
wissenschaftlern in der islamischen welt
nicht wirklich interessant ist das ist
dem volk niemand ich würde gerne mal für
die zuschauer etwas klarer machen frauen
schwer sagen sie was für sie was ist für
sie der islam und wie viel hat er mit
dem terror zum beispiel der es zu tun
ich glaube es gibt ganz klare grundlagen
ganz wieder da ist sich sogar die
gesamte islamische welt so zersplittert
und so unterschiedlicher meinungen sich
bei anderen täglich ist sie sich einig
die quellen des islams ist der koran
gilt auf dem als offenbarung als
heiliges buch gottes
es ist eben die überlieferungen praxis
des propheten und da fängt aber schon
der erste unterschied an
also was es gibt einige die sagen ist
die berufen sich auf überlieferungen die
aber im widerspruch zum koran stehen und
das ist der erste punkt wo ich sagen
würde die überlieferung geht im koran
widersprechen die müssen abgelehnt
werden also frau bestellt ebenso viel
ein beispiel gebracht blasphemie und
apostasie das ist in der tat ein großes
problem etwa die hälfte der sogenannten
islamischen länder haben die todesstrafe
auf apostasie formulierte sie als dass
man sie das war man glauben ablegen die
glaubensfreiheit in diesen ländern
und da ist was unsere unterschiede
vierte kalif unsere gemeinde getan hat
das ist ein ganz springende punkt er hat
anhand der islamischen quellen also das
ist jetzt keine meinung die private
software sondern er hat
anhand des korans anhand der islamischen
quellen an hat der sunna des propheten
zu einer überlieferung seiner praxis
nachgewiesen dass dieser theologischen
standpunkt nicht haltbar ist und ich
glaube das ist der diskurs zu führen
müssen sie haben ja recht haben ja recht
ist in der islamischen welt es keine
freie meinungsäußerung möglich ist da
gibt es eine staats theologie da gibt es
zensur da sind meinungen wie meine
lieder mit dem wissen sie wie zensiert
aber in deutschland wo wir ein anderes
klima wo wir diese diskurse füllen
müssen müssen wir diesen islamischen
diskurs auch führen und dann ist sechs
mal das was sie hier sagen auch wirklich
in ihren gemeinden um weil gerade auf
der fahrt hierher mich hat ein
pakistaner
zum flughafen gebracht und er ist
befreundet mit 1 ahmadi dieser magie hat
einen sohn der ist 19 jahre alt der hat
sich entschieden eine eine europäerin zu
heiraten
daraufhin ist er von seinem vater mit
dem tod bedroht werden worden da ist es
von der familie geflüchtet und der vater
wurde von der ahmadiyya gemeinschaft so
extrem unter druck gesetzt und das ist
nicht das erste mal
sie reden sehr eloquent dass das und das
ist auch großartig aber wissen sie mit
dieser eloquenz verharmlosen sie auch
oft dass die die seite der opfer und die
opfer die es in der ahmadiyya
gemeinschaft gibt die kommen dann sehr
oft zu uns und sie berichten von
kopftuchzwang sie berichten von gewalt
innerhalb der gemeinde auch ja ich kenne
genügend asylanten die von der ahmadiyya
gemeinschaft ich habe das in meinem
meinem buch ja detailreich dargestellt
ich sehe diese eidesstattlichen
erklärungen von gewalt in den ahmadiyya
gemeinde ausgeübt wird die zentrale aus
frankfurt hat zum beispiel sehr oft
mädchen angerufen die bei uns zuflucht
gefunden haben wenn sie einen deutschen
freund gehabt haben dann wurden sie von
der gemeinde diszipliniert und das haben
wir persönlich mit bekommen meine
mitarbeiter könnten das erzählt und das
ist die zentrale aus frankfurt und die
leute kennen sie dort ja also ich finde
nächste mal festhalten das ist alles
nicht belegbare behauptungen sind jetzt
so in den raum geworfen werden
sie kann sagen dass frauen bei ihm
gleichberechtigt sind selbstverständlich
muss man zwei dinge hier klar weil diese
vorwürfe einfach jetzt im raum sind
jahren mit dem thema das die einzige
gemeinschaft in deutschland einzige
muslimische verband in den
körperschaftsstatus erhalten hat und das
nicht ohne kohle natürlich wetter genau
untersucht und überprüft und das was ich
zu tun um noch wegzukommen von dieser
gemeinde an sich das problem dass sie an
gerissen haben ist ein grundsätzliches
es geht nämlich darum muss unterscheiden
zwischen der lehre und der praxis ich
würde jetzt nicht sagen alle muslime
sind super aufgeklärt und alle ahmadi
muslime leben ein gleichberechtigtes
miteinander genauso wenig wie eben auch
alle christen das nicht tun wir haben
viele christen den gefängnissen sitzen
weil die straffälligen kriminell
geworden sind und ich würde nicht
behaupten es hätte etwas mit der
christlichen lehre zu töten
das möchte ich gerne auch von ihnen
würden sie den unterschied machen es
gibt aber die muslime die vielleicht
irgendetwas getan haben was nicht
rechtens ist aber dass der gemeinde und
der lehre vorzuwerfen das wird passiert
auch was lernen das ist nicht rechtens
aber der terror des islamischen staates
geschieht im namen des islam wichtig und
das ist schon und dagegen müssen wir
vorgehen
wir haben ja dachte sich auch uns
journalisten und wissenschaftlern wir
haben nach dem elften september 14
jahren immer wieder gesagt wir müssen
ganz strikt trennen zwischen islam und
islamismus
ich halte das mittlerweile für falsch
wir müssen die gemeinsamkeiten aufzeigen
und klar ansprechen dass es einen
geraden weg geben kann vom islam in den
islamismus einen bruchlosen weg und
aufgabe der islamischen gemeinden finde
ich ist nicht dafür zu sorgen sie
ständig zu distanzieren vom terrorismus
sondern so einen bruch herzustellen
toll was sie über die reform des islam
sagen
ich frage mich nur wirklich ernst
gemeinte frage an sie wenn es diesen
bruch gibt sachen die die nicht mehr
politisiert barkeit des islam oder den
islam zu st jura liz muss fähig zu
machen hat er dann auch dieselbe
anziehungskraft für die gläubigen denn
ein großer teil der anziehungskraft des
islam beruft er darauf dass er ein
umfassendes regelwerk fürs ganze leben
vorgibt für ihre kleidung für ihr
privatleben und solange das so ist frage
ich mich ob er in einer säkularen
pluralistischen gesellschaft bestehen
kann
ich denke schon weil die anziehungskraft
des islams besteht nicht darin dass man
formal irgendwelche gebote einhält
sondern die anziehungskraft ist da
das ist eine spirituelle religion ist
sie den einzelnen zu gott führt es ist
eine dass der einzelne eine möglichkeit
hat eine sehr lebendige beziehung zu
gott auch zu führen und das was aber
passiert im moment ist ja auch wenn man
islamischen staat zum beispiel denken
dass diese vermischung gibt also der
islamische staat diese krise wie dort
ausgerüstet ist ja nicht eine rein
biologische da wird die religion benutzt
es ein vehikel aber wir müssen schon die
rahmenbedingungen betrachten würde ich
ganz motiviert sehen sie denn sagen das
ist eine politische geschichte oder ist
es durch den durch die religion bedingt
dadurch dass es im islam keine trennung
von religion und staat gibt kann man gar
nicht sagen dass es politisch oder
religiös sondern das ist dass es beides
für den islam hat von anfang an der
stadt gesprochen und an der stelle des
einen ursprünglichen islamischen staates
ist die islamische staatengemeinschaft
getreten und was ich was ich schade
finde ist ich glaube das problem des
fundamentalistischen islam wie bei eises
ist im wesentlichen das fundament des
islam
und ich finde wir haben über die reform
gesprochen ich finde das ganze thema
dieser sendung ist reform hindern wenn
man sagt die missbrauchte religion dann
setzt man voraus dass das fundament der
religion an sich okay ist und dass man
den islam gar nicht ändern muss und das
stimmt ja nicht mohammed wird als
beispiel angeführt als moralisches
vorbild das sehen sie genauso wie alle
anderen muslime auch mohamed wenn man
habe zum vorbild nimmt züchtet man
gewalt das heißt ein sarg an seinen
beispiel nicht folgen er hat über 800
jugend enthaupten lassen erst in sieben
fällen die die ermordung seiner seiner
kritiker sie sagen die gewalt ist im
islam begründet und das geht gar nicht
anders
es gibt ja es gebe keine möglichkeit
einen friedlichen islam zu leben
jedenfalls bekommen wir einen
friedlichen und gemäßigten islam nicht
durch leugnen oder lügen und sondern
durch reformieren und die reform das
überlasse ich natürlich der etablierten
theologie und das ist nicht meine
aufgabe als ex muslimen und ich denke
auch gerade die ahmadis können
eigentlich über die reform des islam gar
nicht sprechen weil sie gleich dazu
gehören
herr steinberg wie reformierbar ist der
islam das entscheiden die muslime selbst
und selbstverständlich gehören die
ahmadis zu den muslimen wenn sie das
wollen und wenn sie sich wie sie das tun
auf den koran und auf den propheten
beziehen und sie sind sicherlich auch
eine der gemeinden und deswegen haben
sie tatsächlich diesen
körperschaftsstatus bekommen der geprüft
wurde mit denen wir sehr gut klar kommen
können hier in deutschland als deutschen
muslime ich glaube aber auch dass diese
dass wir bei isis und bei al kaida
mit diesem terminus der missbrauchten
religion etwas zu schnell an der hand
sind diese leute befinden sich nun in
einer tradition
das ist eine minderheits tradition in
der islamischen welt aber eine die seit
dem 18 jahrhundert enorm an an stärke
gewonnen hat die ihre wurzeln hat und
deren vertreter meine ich auch zu recht
behaupten dass die fromme muslime sind
ich halte osama bin laden für einen
höchstkurs liegt bei mach da die bin ich
mir nicht so ganz sicher aber auch da
gibt es einige einige hinweise oder
erworben und auch bei den bei den vielen
dschihadisten ist das so ich glaube aber
dass wir dann trotzdem in diesem rahmen
ganz genau trennen müssen wir haben die
dschihadisten die müssen wir bekämpfen
vielleicht müssen wir die sogar töten
wie al qaida und hieß es wir haben die
islamisten die sicherlich ein
politisches problem sind gerade wenn sie
hier in deutschland leben und nicht in
saudi arabien und wir haben so und so
viele muslime die einfach durch ihre
alltägliche praxis zeigen dass sie
überhaupt kein problem überhaupt kein
problem sind so vieles durcheinander
geht wir können sie tatsächlich an so
ein paar dingen messen die ein problem
sind das stichwort ist hier schon schon
gekommen dass apostasie verbot das ist
auch für viele konservative muslime ein
problem das man jetzt eigentlich
verlassen krismer die religion auch nach
orthodoxer ansicht nicht verlassen kann
das ist zum beispiel etwas das müssen
wir muslimen abverlangen und das leisten
ja auch einige muslime hier dass sie
sagen
selbstverständlich kann der muslim zum
christen werden sagt zentralrat der
muslime der hat damit immer das problem
wird ganz gerne
dass wir nicht so eine innere
muslimische debatte jetzt zu viel
bekommen sondern wirklich auch mal denkt
was was viele bürger ja bewegt dass sie
was ich hab das ja am anfang gesagt dass
der islam so viele gesichter hat und
dass da vieles durcheinander geht wie
frau hübsch nehmen sie menschen die
angst vor dem islam viele gerade wenn
die flüchtlinge in viele flüchtlinge
kommen sagen wir befürchten zum einen
dass terroristen kommen und wir
befürchten auch dass menschen kommen die
nicht zu uns passen weil sie bestimmte
werte nicht anerkennen ich glaube ein
wesentlicher faktor das einfach an
vielen studien die untersuchen woher
kommt die angst vor muslimen ist dass es
ganz wichtig ist es für einen kontakt zu
muslimen herstellen also in dem moment
wo menschen persönliche erfahrungen mit
muslimen haben wo sie muslime
kennenlernen wo sie merken das sind
normale menschen die haben gewisse werte
und das sind durchaus auch werte dem
islam angelegt sind ähnlich im
christentum und im judentum wo es um
selbstlosigkeit geht es um
nachbarschaftlich kite und solidarität
mit armen und schwachen geht das sind
werte die veranlagt sind in den
religionen und wenn die menschen kontakt
zu muslimen und merken das sind menschen
wie du und ich
dann sind ganz viele längst schon mal
abgebaut ja aber natürlich auch glück
weil die erfahrung erzählen die
erfahrung macht dass ihr nicht die hand
gegeben wird dass sie singen ein ganz
großes spiel mensch wie du und ich dann
hat sie das gefühl das ist jemand anders
der meine werte hier in diesem land
nicht abzüglich glaube da gibt es auch
diese klassischen kulturelle
missverständnisse also das mit dem hand
geben ist so ein sehr schönes beispiel
dafür
weil eben wir haben jetzt lange darüber
diskutiert warum wird nicht die hand
gegeben ist wird als affront verstanden
dem islamischen kulturkreis ist es aber
kein affront es ist einfach toll hier
muss ich wem anpassen dass die erwärmung
leben anpassen ich glaube es gibt zwei
dinge zum einen natürlich muss man sich
immer in die aufnahmegesellschaft
integrieren muss sich anpassen aber es
gibt bestimmte grenzen wir haben für die
religionsfreiheit also wenn man von mir
verlangen würde ich müsste mich mit
meiner kleidung anpassen dann tue ich
das stück weit natürlich aber ich möchte
trotzdem das recht hat mein kopftuch zu
tragen wenn jemand erst jetzt als als
seiner praxis versteht menschen des
anderen geschlechts nicht durch an die
hand zu geben dann ist es jetzt kein
gebot des korans aber er muss sich
verständlich machen
und er muss ins gespräch kommen entweder
er macht er das erklärt dass es nichts
damit zu tun hat dass es irgendwie um
frauenverachtung geht das ist ja ein
missverständnis in der luft liegt
sondern erklärt warum er das nicht tut
oder
er meidet öffentliche platzierung gerne
ihre meinung dazu hören was ganz banal
bei diesem beispiel weil es jetzt so
viel diskutiert worden ist dass hand
geben
also ich denke an immer an hand geben
und wir haben noch leichter diskutieren
wenn es dann eben nicht die tausenden
zwangsheiraten und ehrenmord gäbe gäbe
und die tausenden opfer und wir betreuen
ja auch viele dieser opfer und das mit
mit dem kopftuch und mit der hand geben
ist ja auch eine apartheid ein zeichen
für apartheid wir ich bin eine
koranschule in einem adresse in pakistan
gegangen und unser lehrer saß immer
hinter einem vorhang weil mann und frau
nicht sich in die augen schauen dürfen
und dass das sie sagt das hat es einfach
kulturelle und das ist ja aber man muss
sich verständlich machen also ich glaube
es hat etwas mit der sexualität der frau
zu tun
die frau wird als eine versuchung
gesehen deswegen das haben wir in der
koranschule auch so gelernt
eine frau muss sich verschleiern damit
der mann durch ihre sexualität noch
nicht in versuchung gerät deswegen muss
sie auch ihr kopftuch tragen und ich
habe etwas dagegen als sexobjekt
abgestempelt zu werden und ich denke
dass diese art von begründungen die
werden sie nie in pakistan finden fragen
sie mal in pakistan jemanden warum man
sich nicht die hand geben darf natürlich
es ist eine ein zeichen der geschlechter
apartheid nicht wie sie das ist nun
gerade erklärt haben warum herr wegner
reden hier warum legen sie uns solche
debatten immer so auf warum um identität
geht um das was wir glauben unsere
gesellschaft ausmacht und unsere werte
und ich finde wir das ist auch eine
herausforderung die uns jetzt die
flüchtlinge mit geben
wir werden neu lernen müssen darüber zu
reden wie wir solche identitäten
begründen sie sollen ihr kopftuch tragen
aber ich werde ihnen auch sagen das ist
nicht angenehm finde weil für mich das
signal ist dass sie als muslima
behandelt werden möchten als erstes und
das finde ich für mich schonmal es
zunächst mal du zu modulieren auferlegen
das in ordnung aber sie werden ertragen
müssen dass man ihm dass er genauso wenn
meine frau nicht die hand gibt werde ich
ihr sagen ich halte das für unhöflich
ich halte es für rückständig weil dir
wird nichts passieren möchte die hand
gebe du wirst dich unrein dadurch
ganz einfach finde ich einen ton finden
in dem was möglich ist auszusprechen
in respekt aber nicht zu sagen im
falschen heuchlerischen respekt das habe
vielleicht zu lange getan
ich finde es schon schwierig wenn jetzt
in der luft liegt das ist oft solche
missverständnisse und ford hält die
glaub ich in der luft liegen es ist ja
nicht so dass die frau den mann nicht
die hand gibt weil sie irgendwie denkt
sie wird dadurch unrein oder umgekehrt
es geht hier um einen ganz allgemeines
verhalten verhaltens auf diesem geschäft
also anders ist in unserer gesellschaft
ist und die muslime teil unserer
gesellschaft werden wollen ist warum
nehmen sie da nicht diese man muss
unsere verhalten an dem niemand muss
schon schauen dass man wo man abstriche
macht und da gibt es eben bestimmte
grenzen
also natürlich kann man von muslimen die
sich die herkommen verlangen dass sie
sich so einen großen fall integrieren
aber in dem moment wo sie keinen
gesetzen widersprechen keine gesetze
verstoßen und im gegenteil sie haben das
recht auf religionsfreiheit das mag eine
zumutung sein das mag dem einen oder
anderen nicht gefallen deswegen wäre ich
immer dafür dass man das gespräch sucht
und sich erklärt zum beispiel dass bei
dem die hand geben wir brauchen das ich
gar nicht so dass ich gar nicht mehr
weiter geht es eben nicht um das was
hier im raum steht die frau ich bin da
ganz bayern ich möchte auch kein
sexualobjekt sein und das sind so
debatten über den islam geführt werden
aber wir haben hier ein auszug steinberg
wie empfinden sie das wenn immer über
diese dinge also an diesen symbolen
immer fest gemacht hat sind es den boden
oder ist es einfach dann doch viel mehr
sagt dieses hand geben das kopftuch
genau was über die stellung der frau mit
der viele in unserer gesellschaft
einfach ein problem haben ich glaube es
sagt sehr viel über uns aus aber weniger
über über die leute über die wir über
die wir reden ich muss gestehen ich sehe
das nicht als zumutung überhaupt nicht
und ich bin auch daran gewöhnt dass
frauen wir nicht die hand geben
es ist vielmehr ein gebot der
höflichkeit wenn man mal in der
arabischen welt länger gelebt hat dass
man eben eine frau nicht immer direkt
seine pranke hin fast immer dann wenn
man länger in der deutschen gesellschaft
liegt
wir leben in berlin an unhöflichkeit
glaube ich an ein update der kern des
ganzen ist ich sehe darin tatsächlich
kein problem weil sind das sind aspekte
der persönlichen religiösen lebens
führung kam die ich so akzeptieren
daher wird das auch so gehört wohl am
ende er wird das akzeptieren eine burka
zu tragen was ich nur sage ist wir
werden uns darüber streiten können
müssen dass ich glaube auch man kann als
frau damit leben dass ein mann nicht die
hand gibt solange man das gefühl man hat
irgendwie zumindest noch die gleichen
rechte deshalb würde ich ganz gerne mal
nach ihrer erfahrung jetzt fragen wir
haben jetzt viele flüchtlinge bei uns
mit einem anderen hintergrund frequenz
was sind jetzt ihre erfahrungen mit
frauen was hören sie von den frauen in
den flüchtlingslagern
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel wir kennen
eine frau die zwangsverheiratet wurde
und sie hat gegen die gewalt des mannes
angekämpft hat ihn auch immer wieder
gemeldet dann hat die polizei den mann
verboten sich dem haus zu nähern und hat
auch geschafft dass er warf asyl da
abgeschoben wurde
jetzt ist dadurch die flüchtlingswelle
wieder zurückgekommen und ist nicht der
einzige fall
wir haben frauen die von ihren familien
flüchten also dieses bundesweit ein
problem und diese frauen bekommen vom
staat kein schutz und tier ist glaube
ich das erste problem dass wir kein
opferschutz haben für die die sich
wirklich integrieren wollen das heißt
integrationswilligen und die opfer des
islamismus werden im stich gelassen
während man islamkonferenzen und alles
mögliche hat ich würde mir vielleicht
mal eine opfer konferenz wünschen was
sind denn die die die probleme der opfer
wir haben jetzt auch eine junge dame die
es gerade hier auch in berlin lebt sie
ist auch zu uns gekommen
sie war homosexuell familie wollte sie
zwangsverheiratet und bei ihr war es zum
beispiel so dass die tante in einer bank
gearbeitet hat und über die bank hat sie
herausgefunden wo das opfer sich
aufgehalten hat und hat dann quasi das
der familie verraten das heißt nicht
einmal da an solchen stellen kann
sich mehr darauf verlassen dass man
geschützt ist weil die loyalität
innerhalb der gemeinschaft immer höher
ist als loyalität zum opfer und ich
persönlich muss sagen ich bin aus
pakistan geflüchtet in der hoffnung in
deutschland in europa die menschenrechte
als frau wahrnehmen zu können und die
erfahrung mache ich dass es hier auch
nicht mehr geht und dass europa
solidarität zeigt aber mit den falschen
nämlich die die uns unterdrücken und die
die aber ganz konkret wo zeigt der
bundesregierung solidarität mit denen
die sie unterdrücken indem man indem man
zb formulieren formulierungen nimmt
indem man zb sagt die bösen
differenzieren aber dann differenziert
man nicht zwischen demokratischen
undemokratischen muslimen und lässt
diejenigen die gewalt ausüben und
lehrern auch hier leben ohne
konsequenzen
wir haben menschen die hier in moscheen
zu gewalt aufrufe zum schlagen der frau
aufrufen
und das passiert ihnen gar nichts ich
finde diese menschen schlecht wie das
über schicken würden sie das wort ich
hoffe dass wenn das beobachtet werden
und einfliegen moscheen ist der
verfassungsschutz ja auch unterwegs und
dass das dann berichtet wird und das ist
natürlich ein straftat da muss man
schicken warum warum wir haben ihm ein
überwachungsstaat bei der zahl von
islamisten die auf uns zukommt wir haben
über 40.000 islamisten in deutschland
die jederzeit gewalt ausüben können und
ich frage mich was spricht dagegen wenn
man diese menschen wieder in die
islamistischen länder also das hat
durchaus kontrolliert was wird in den
moscheen gepredigt also das finde ich
nicht falsch
da das ist ja auch eine pflicht gibt
natürlich und die predigten so zu
gestalten dass sie zwar auf deutsch sind
und dass wir natürlich dem grundgesetz
nicht widersprechen also das sollte
konsens sein das sind ja so minimale
forderungen die man stellen kann aber zu
unterstellen das wäre hier großflächiges
problem das halte ich doch dann schon
vielleicht über das team bisher an einer
studie vom bundesinnenministerium wonach
es tausende islamisten gibt die polizei
ist völlig überfordert wie haben gebiete
in berlin wo man nicht normal mehr
hineingehen darf die berliner richterin
kirsten heisig hat da ein eindrückliches
buch darüber geschrieben das ende der
geduld und hat dabei steht
schon auf deutsch gibt viele starken
hinweis darauf geben dass ein wichtiger
faktor um präventiv vor dem terrorismus
auch zu schützen
der star diego hier gemeinden eine große
rolle spielen wenn man weiß dass
muslimische junge menschen die religiös
sozialisiert sind nicht anfällig sind
für radikalisierung aixtron ist
natürlich man weiß dass all diejenigen
die euch haben rekrutieren lassen
theorien dass die das gift aus
religiösen häusern kommen nicht aus wie
die gesehenen häusern kommen dass es oft
das auf junge menschen waren deren
säkularen lie 2 gelebt haben die am
alkohol getrunken drogen dann sind auch
freitags gegangen und haben sich später
direkt in den linken seite was war ihr
die verantwortung vom lamm glaube das
steht dass der islam ein partner sein
kann dass man sozusagen es ist mehr
religion präventiv schützend wirken kann
und wir die religion gar nicht
verteufeln müssen würden sie dann ein
fundiertes wissen über die religion kann
schon auch hilfreich sein um zu schützen
dass die jungen menschen sich nicht auf
solche rattenfänger einlassen würden wir
die zahlen erst in ordnung dass mit dem
40.000 islamisten das ist wirklich
unsinn
das sind diejenigen die in
islamistischen organisationen wie zum
beispiel den zentralrat der muslime
militärisch und so weiter organisiert
sind
das sind alles keine gewalttätigen
organisation jürgen problem
problematisch sein aber sie sind nicht
gewalttätig werden so etwa mit 1000 bis
2000 statisten hier in deutschland zu
tun dazu kommen andere organisationen
die anhänger haben jeweils so im bereich
dreistellige dreistellige zahl und wenn
wir uns dann aber angucken wer darunter
geht dann muss man feststellen dass das
profil nicht eindeutig ist sind viele
dabei die schon aus religiösen
elternhäusern kommen und zwar aus
islamistisch religiösen elternhäusern
kommen bis hin zu denen die tatsächlich
innerhalb von 12 monaten die die erst
konvertieren und innerhalb von 12
monaten in diese szene rutschen denn
mittlerweile eine sehr sehr große szene
derjenigen die nach die nach syrien
gehen aber es ist natürlich richtig dass
in dem moment in dem die in anderen
traditionen unterwegs sind nicht
islamistischen traditionen in einem
starken konservativen islam türkischer
prägung arabischer prägung bei den
ahmadis bei den aleviten dass sie dann
natürlich keine das dann natürlich keine
gefahr besteht dass sie dort runter
gehen
wir müssen uns schon schon überlegen in
welchem maße muslimische organisationen
auch partner sein können
da müssen wir sehr vorsichtig sein aber
ich denke die ahmadis können dass sein
die alle wie es können dass sein und
auch einige sunnitische organisation die
vielen zehntausend flüchtlinge die jetzt
kommen dass die auch eine chance sein
können gemeinsam den islam zu
modernisieren in deutschland wenn das
geschickt angestellt wird
wir haben wir doch aus den fehlern der
letzten 40 jahre bei der integration
oder beim entstehen von
parallelgesellschaften in deutschland
auch nicht was gelernt und das ist dass
wir eben mit falscher toleranz probleme
nicht beseitigen sondern sie noch
schlimmer machen und ich glaube die
lektion sitzt tief und wenn wir es jetzt
schaffen auf eine angemessene art unsere
werte zu vermitteln die auch attraktiv
die nicht chauvinistische wirkt oder von
oben herab aber dass uns da noch mit es
gibt ja mehrere reformer im islam in
deutschland ist nicht nur die ahmadiyya
viele die sagen wir müssen den islam
endlich zweifelsfrei vereinbar machen
mit dem liberalen pluralistischen
rechtsstaat gibt es und richtig in die
pflicht zu nehmen und zu sagen wir
dürfen wir dürfen jetzt nicht mehr
dasselbe laissez-faire üben wie wir das
vor 30 40 jahren noch gemacht haben dass
wir jetzt die große chance
ich möchte noch mal auf diese zahl
kommen weil er gesagt hat das wäre ein
unsinn es ist kein unsinn ich sehe es
kommt auch darauf an wie man den begriff
islamist definiert für mich ist ein
islamist nicht nur derjenige der es
irgendwelche andersgläubigen tötet
sondern für michael ist ein islamist
auch derjenige der seine frau schlägt
und und ein ehrenmord und so weiter und
diese welt bei sehr viel islamisten ist
ein globales phänomen die
weltgesundheitsorganisation spricht
seien etwa de mission ausmacht dass
gewalt gegen frauen angeht dann haben
wir weltweit 100 millionen ist wurde
erst 95 vergewaltigung in der ehe
strafbar gestellt und dazu wurde bei der
cdu sogar der fraktionszwang aufgehoben
also auch das hat lange gedauert bis wir
in welcher schule kugel ich sagen okay
ich sage nur es gibt auch also auch wir
waren nicht immer so auf
wie wir uns jetzt geben teilweise und
jetzt ich würde jetzt aber einfach gerne
mal nach vorn schauen wir bittner das
gesagt hat wenn wir jetzt wenn wir sagen
die vielen flüchtlinge die jetzt kommen
sehen sie darin auch eine chance dass
man sagt mir die sie kommen in diese
gesellschaft und was müssen wir dafür
leisten damit es einen ja einen
aufgeklärten islam geben kann
ich glaube alles entgegenkommen der
deutschen gesellschaft kann nicht
reichen wenn diejenigen die hier
herkommen das gefühl haben sie dürfen
hier bleiben selbst wenn sie die
menschenrechte verweigern
das ist einmal das erste und zweitens
habe ich aus der praxis die erfahrung
gemacht dass das ist mein eindruck das
denn wirklich verfolgten gar nicht
geholfen wird
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel eben diese
iranische familie die in iran zum
christentum konvertiert sind
der vater wurde daraufhin gerichtet die
familie ist in ein anderes islamisches
land was nachbarlandes geflüchtet dann
hat diese familie uns gefragt ob wir
helfen können wir haben die cdu gefragt
ob man dieser familie asyl geben kann
und ich habe das schriftlich können wir
nachlesen
leider können wir dieser familie nicht
helfen weil kein bezug zu deutschland
besteht
und ich könnte es ganz viele andere
fälle wenn sie wollen aufzählen und den
wird nicht geholfen und dafür nicht ist
es schon fatal wie hier sieben und die
orientalischen christen haben keinen
eigenen staat mehr in der region
und eigentlich müsste man diese leute
bevorzugt aufnehmen und die islamischen
länder und die golf staaten dazu
verpflichten dass ihre glaubensbrüder
aufnehmen trotz ich würde gerne mal hier
in deutschland bleiben erstellen büro
sagen sie gibt eine möglichkeit dass man
den islam insofern dass es dass wir hier
und miteinander leben können
nach unseren grundwerten geht das
überhaupt selbstverständlich geht es wie
haben 4,3 millionen muslime hier leben
und selbst wenn es stimmt dass diese
40.000 islamisten nun ihre morde begehen
und und gewalttätig sind dann ist das
problem immer noch beherrschbar letzten
endes ist das allerdings eine indoor
muslimische debatte ich glaube dass wir
über die großen probleme reden dann
müssen wir zunächst einmal darauf
schauen ob wir vielleicht akteure hier
im land haben die problematisch sind und
einwirken und ich glaube die haben wir
haben den saudi arabischen staat der
sich jetzt als partner anbietet wir
haben den türkischen staat der sich
schon seit jahren als
partner anbietet obwohl er immer weniger
partner wird wir haben solche akteure
wie die gülen-bewegung aus der türkei
die jetzt auch immer aktiver wird und da
glaube ich müssen wir zunächst mal
aufpassen und schauen dass wir nicht
muslimen ihren freien raum hier ihre
freie öffentliche sphäre verbauen indem
wir auswärtige akteure hereinlassen die
behaupten teil der lösung zu sein aber
teil des problems sind ich glaube dass
die weste die beste variante ist wenn
man wirklich eine muslimische reform
haben will dass man freien religiösen
diskurs zulässt das machen wir hier in
europa ganz generell aber ich glaube
dass wir auch bildungsstätten dafür
brauchen
an den universitäten für muslime nicht
islam wissenschaftliche lehrstühle
sondern theologische lehrstühle die auch
so ein bisschen dieser pluralität der
gesamten szene wirkung schaffen wir
müssen uns auf die mentalen härter
formulieren ich finde das muss
vollkommen ausgeschlossen sein dass
saudi arabien hier auch nur eine moschee
finanziert der wahabismus ist eine
verachtung religio türkei ist das
größere problem der flächen wird machte
größeres team aber über radikalismus
frieden deutlich sagen sind hier nicht
erwünscht
aber das ist eben glaube ich das große
problem also wenn wir uns das global
betrachten diese krisenherde die hat
also wo ist die fluchtursachen das ist
ja eine zentrale frage
da ist natürlich schon ein ganz klarer
grund dafür dass viele menschen hier
kommen müssen
das sollte dafür dass überhaupt
terrorismus gedeiht das sei ein
nährboden für terrorismus entstehen kann
es ist natürlich dass da eine große
frustration vor euch in diesen ländern
was damit sie wundert es ist ein
wahrhaft arabische regime gibt ihr
furchtbar schlecht regieren die korrupt
sind aber dass das oft auch unsere
bündnispartner waren also dass wir mit
den schlimmsten despoten und diktatoren
gemeinsame sache gemacht haben sie lange
sie prowestlich eingestellt waren das
würde andere beim namen von
menschenrechten einmarschiert sind um
unsere eigenen interessen zu verfolgen
und diese doppelmoral das wird natürlich
dort registriert aber kann
thulium nicht reformiert also ich
versteh 1 lahm als das christentum so
alt war wie der islam heute also 1430
jahre
da gab es schon reformatorischen
bewegungen mutter kam später aber es gab
ja es gab schon glücklich wird in
großbritannien
und ich frage mich warum unter
bedingungen heute die eigentlich viel
einfacher sind für reformatoren dieser
islam sich nicht schon längst viel mehr
reformiert hat die reformatoren justiz
ja dazu wie viel wird ich glaube es
liegt einfach die christlichen
reformatoren hatten es auch ein bisschen
einfacher jesus hat nie gewalt gelernt
oder verbrannten ja logisch oder
ausgeübten mohammed hat gewalt gelehrt
und ausgeübt und ich denke das ist schon
ein sehr großer unterschied in den
religionsgründer werde es denn wäre es
denn hilfreich für die reformation des
islam
wenn von uns sehr mit bestimmte
bündnispartner dürfen müssten strenger
müssen wir strenger und den aber wenn
auch von den muslimen hier viel klar
na das passt ja auch frau klöckner wir
brauchen eine gebrauchsanweisung und die
brauchen so eine hausordnung würde das
dann helfen dass dann alle daran dass
das glaube ich sehr wohl also ich glaube
die integration muss verpflichtend sein
wie viele menschen die hierher kommen
wie ich vorhin schon gesagt habe weil
die menschenrechts menschenrechte
verweigert
er soll wieder zurückgeschickt werden
gerade bei den flüchtlingen die jetzt
kommen
schon das wäre dass wir dazu neigen
probleme zu kulturalisierung und das auf
eine ebene jetzt transportieren also
dass sie allein ist ein problematisieren
natürlich ich bin davor das ist ja auch
so eine archäologische krise gibt aber
wie es peter ist so schön gesagt hat der
krieg ist also terrorist der krieg der
armen und krieg ist der terror der
reichen also es gibt schon global
politische zusammenhänge die dazu führen
dass eine region jetzt völlig instabil
geworden ist und die dazu führen
wenn hier nur als auch überall auf der
samischen welt als auch in indien haben
die massenvergewaltigung worüber
diskutiert wird es gibt auch in
deutschland probleme mit der
gleichberechtigung als aber sie in einer
region die krisenhafte er ist ja nicht
wenn man ein problem meinte solveen
statische regime haben ist natürlich die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dort auch
schwache und am unterdrückt werden dass
er eine diskriminierung von minderheiten
von frauen gibt größer aber war ein land
was bildung gibt wusste stabile soziale
umschau bei ihrem orden und
zwangsheiraten gibt sie auch in
deutschland ja aber die gibt es auch
eben es gibt auch familien haben die
jede woche in der zeitung stehen und es
gibt auch ehrenmorde und nicht so
gefragt warum steigen
warum ich verstehe es jetzt nicht
natürlich gibt es auch christen die ihre
frauen ermorden überhaupt keine frage
aber viele das problem der zwangsheirat
und der ehrenmordes an muslimisches
problem warum sagen sie nicht
das lehne ich ab und da möchte ich also
ich würde ich das was ich ganz klar
sagen sie zeigen jetzt ist kein
muslimisches problem weil sie ihren mann
kann das land nicht angelegt ist es wird
so viel auf die quellen des islams bis
gebe es gibt keine einzige stelle im
koran visionären ort angreifen kann
bestimmt unter christen also das ist
kein der kausalzusammenhang ist nicht da
jetzt natürlich da was sehen also das
ist zwar zwei dinge gleichzeitig
passiert unter muslimen gibt es viel
ehrenmorde da sage ich schauen sie sich
mal an wies die analphabetenrate die ich
im bildungsrat der frauen ist okay wir
haben am ende der welt es gab den
begriff ehrenmord nicht aber die praxis
und prophet mohammed hat selbst dazu
aufgerufen zb menschen zu töten wenn sie
den islam ablehne sache al bukhari 3017
nummer 3017 ganz klar damit gesagt wenn
jemand den islam verlässt soll er
getötet werden das kann jeder nachlesen
dann weiß auch jeder
nicht mehr lösen in den letzten
anderthalb minuten die ich gerne nutzen
würde um noch mal ganz gut mit ihnen
davon zu schauen
herr steinberg denken sie dass die
flüchtlinge eine chance sein können den
islam wirklich zu reformieren wie und
was muss da jetzt konkret schnell auch
von der politik geschehen
ich glaube überhaupt nicht dass es da
einen zusammenhang gibt diese
flüchtlinge die werden genug damit zu
tun haben ihre probleme die sie
mitgebracht haben aus syrien aus
afghanistan zu verarbeiten und dann hier
vielleicht irgendwann mal einen job zu
finden das wird schwierig genug bei
denen sie bei diesen ganzen vielen
jungen männern wenn wir über reform des
islam oder überhaupt des deutschen islam
reden dann müssen wir uns an diejenigen
wenden die schon eine lange zeit hier
sind die an den unis studieren die da
schon grundlage haben aber ansonsten
sehe ich da tatsächlich keine keine
verbindung eine der wichtigsten aufgaben
für die politik ist einfach zu
verhindern dass die konflikte die wir
schon sehen im moment noch einmal zu
nehmen also sprich ein anschlag
verhindern um damit ein anwachsen von
von islamkritischen ressentiments zu
zumindest zumindest zu vermeiden
vielleicht so ein bisschen das ganze zu
reduzieren ganz kurzen zum schluss nach
james wan denken sie können sie wieder
so leben und so reisen ohne geschützt
werden zu müssen
ich glaube das wird nicht möglich sein
und sagt mit auch die polizei sie können
mich vor den islamisten nicht schützen
vielen dank herr steinberg bittner frau
hübsch vielen dank für die diskussion
nächste woche ist mein kollege da sind
sie ein kollege alexander kähler für sie
da bis dahin tschüss